we have divided in three our kingdom  it is our fast intent to shake all cares  and business for my age conferring the  money younger strengths what can you say  to draw a third more opulent than your  sisters  nothing my lord nothing will come of  nothing speak again my daughter by day  and night he wrongs me every hour he  flushes into one gross crime all rather  that sets us all that all does not  endure it  who is it that didn't tell me who I am  why not by the handsome alibi offended  should be ruled and lived by some  discretion that discerns your state  thou art my daughter rather than disease  that's it night next so I brother  [Music]  here I stand the slave before infirm  weak the despised on  case  I am a man more sinned against than  sinning  better though that's not been born and  not off pleased me better  you